you talk to
me everything I touch turns into a
disaster I guess I don't know what
Christmas is all about isn't there
anyone who knows what Christmas is all
about sure Charlie Brown I can tell you
what Christmas is all
[Music]
about lights please Christmas is just
another excuse for white Christian
capitalists to shove their wealth and
religion in the faces of marginalized
people it has nothing to do with the
birth of Jesus who wasn't even born on
December 25th your Christmas isn't the
only holiday Charlie Brown what about
Hanukkah Quanza where is the school
place to celebrate Ule or the Hallmark
movies wishing everyone a merry winter
solstice how about the dwali Festival of
Lights you never heard of the Dali
festival of lights did you don't get me
started on the Salvation Army all this
because a America is a quasi religious
anti-lgbtq AIP oligarchy where Christmas
is thrust upon us and Everyone Falls for
materialism each year like the good
little Mindless sheep they are and they
follow their Shepherd Donald
[Music]
Trump and that's what Christmas is all
about you sis white
male oh
brother
remember none of this is possible
without you join the fight and sign up
for mug club today at louder withcer
docomo club for $89 annually join the
fight at louth credit.com mugclub
[Music]
[Applause]
today that's what I
[Music]
know oh glad to be with you uh speakers
off right Yakuza yes sir okay it was a
little bit of a rush here before we got
into the got into the show my question
the day is there anybody out there who
you um it's wrong to
hate says
who despise more hate more than LeBron
James you got to work hard at it so
we'll be talking about that and more
bring up the rundown LeBron James today
reminds us why he is a piece of human
excrement uh YouTube has openly
shadowbanned us for the first time
letting us know oh that's nice it's not
so much Shadow Banning so much as
sunbathe Banning
now uh president gay of Harvard M yummy
she she's gotten off uh off the she's
off the is it on the hook or off the
hook I think it's off I don't know off
the hook she's also gotten anyway also
I'm not going to encourage by right off
right of the shoot because we have in
third chair it's like it's I look at any
point today if you see
this head on over to rumble because
they've let us know that they have their
eye on us and then on mug club today we
will talk about how the mayor of Boston
hates white people even though she's a
Asian yeah she's a Asian lady and and
uh second in command Captain Morgan
Gerald how are you I am doing well sir
how are you I'm happy by the way to see
I asked you a question I don't care
about the answer I I I just I'm happy to
see your shirt you you approve Die Hard
is a Christmas yeah you know I lost a
bet yeah you know I lost a bet y like
the movie I just don't think it's a
Christmas film you guys can comment no
it's not really it's not just because
they toss in a Christmas tree they did
throw Professor Snape off a cliff though
that's true didn't let him know
surprised him yeah and in third shair
when you hear this you can watch him on
mug Club Monday through Thursday 5:00
p.m. Eastern and May 11th he's going to
be at the count bayy Center for the Arts
I've done that Theater Great theater in
Red Bank New Jersey uh get to see the
funniest man alive funniest in at
working today and you know hey I don't
know how how many more chances you'll
have to go see him because he's probably
not long for this world Nick depalo how
are
you you heard about the diagnosis I did
yeah you list is a Christmas movie but
nobody agrees H there's snow that's not
snow there yes it is is snow yeah oh
you're darker than everybody look at
look what well I don't like the
implication me either and Hitler was a
Santa to a lot of people he was to a lot
of to his people yeah I kid everybody
also Santa was a Hitler to some people
that's the thing too that's actually
Rudolph Island of Misfit Toys that's
just the
handicaps like what about a choo Cho
with a square wheel first off you know
you can get new Wheels the squirt gun
that only shoty jelly oh that's an
unsolvable problem to Santa he put them
in trinka for toys
can't arue that reason what do you do
with a boat that can't stay afloat it's
a shipwreck you put uh slaves on it
yes that's Rudolph 2 a great joke and
the reason this will never see the light
of day and believe me I loaded for beer
today cuz these three subjects really
tickle my
fancy boat who's carrying
aastad chandu however your years chooo
by the way we all have to admit that we
are jealous of that man that man has
aged very well
I don't know Amad the black guy yeah I
would know give us free that guy I don't
like those movies he has a post he look
at he has a poster of him above his wall
like Farah faucet in the 70s all right
while how do you know I had that I had
it
waterproofed before we move on Chris
Cuomo hey's you know he's your brethren
no he isn't I don't associate with that
left-wing fake
Guinea see you know
what of all the things that are fake
about him probably not the guinea no
you're right he lifts weights while he's
sitting at the computer
Mead he lifts fake weights while sitting
at
[Music]
the ice glass is a welding lateris
Chris Cuomo interviewed a girl with
Tourette's and there is a debate in the
medical community yeah as to whether
this so I want you to to to let us know
if you think this is real and I get it
it's non Tourette's privilege but the
interview with Chris Cuomo went almost
it went exactly how you thought it would
what do you hope you can do by taking
the risks that you take so people can
understand what you're dealing
with I'm sorry do you mind repeating she
sneezing no no
off lit baby we is off you Chris
how has it been as you've gotten more
famous do you believe that people are
understanding better or are they dopes
like me who think you're acting and I
also get very evil people that would
comment and say like go yourself
Chris L to
Bab your own biscuit fat that have told
me that my parents deserve to die that
doesn't seem involuntary clinically
people suck and they're mean and they're
stupid and they try to make themselves
feel better by going after others and
you are the antidote my young friend
because you have my
kids you have my kids repeating your
lines so that it's sounds like a
parenting problem I obviously go to the
gym and I wear headphones and that's
also a very big factor and how somebody
spot me you
cck that's also a really big like part
in my journey I love seeing him in the
videos you guys have a great Bond I love
everything about your family and I love
the story you're telling the people and
living your truth living your truth and
my kids you're done my you know what I
am done I got to go to phone they're
blowing up I don't know if Chris Cuomo
is trolling here now here's the thing
here's the thing I don't it's in
voluntary giving the middle finger and
an entire phrase like it's I knew a kid
who had tette here's and I had the
luxury look just go with me for a second
here I had the luxury of going to grade
school with him so I watched his
Tourette's evolve from where he was in
grade school and it was you know he'd be
writing doing taking an exam and you go
that was it and then it translated to
grabbing my eighth grade girlfriend's
ass he
was it's like it's like a body cavity
search and he said that I don't think
that's involuntary like you have to set
a date in your your calendar so just to
be clear Tourette's is obviously a thing
only 10% of people have Tourette's
blurred out obscenities I don't know the
rate on them actually like doing the up
yours motion or hailing Hitler as part
of but it just seems different tourettes
what do you think Gerald I I I it seemed
performative to me that and I could be
100% wrong she's been do it for a long
time so she's playing long ball I don't
I I don't doubt that she has ter but
really it was the flicking people off I
was like I can understand the cussing
and voluntary and like ticks and things
like that but like to form the the the
motion to like yes middle finger and
it's more like this for the rest of it
I'm like yeah but that seems
uncoordinated this is very coordinated
this is very coordinated so it just
seems like it's a concerted effort it
seems like you really don't like Chris
yeah get in line yeah flop in line with
the rest of
us what do you think I thought that part
was intentional the finger the rest of
it no when he when he laughed at her
yeah I thought you know I don't know how
it works maybe you put a seed in that
crazy
[Music]
head tecal school yeah in about 4
minutes and raka here g
go so I ignore it I go on a little more
g go I go this a tech I go nobody I was
told this is technical it's not
agricultural you thought someone brought
chickens to your show that's what it
sounded like I thought I was in Key
West Roost is running around on the
street I like it though what if you can
have a disease man yeah that's one you
know that that or alcoholism because you
you get to drink a lot of booze yes so
yes that's the funnest one this brings
us to LeBron James I'm sure everyone
here will have a little bit of
Tourette's again if you see the YouTube
dump button uh you know that's where you
just
yeah because we're going to do a segment
too letting you know sort of the new
policies of YouTube and you can help
support us none of this happens without
you mug Club lc.com mugclub you got the
uh free copy of beautiful differences
the children's book once they're gone
they're gone it's between now and
Christmas and I think you have two more
days if you order it for it to be there
for Christmas yeah roughly rough you
know how shipping goes we're eyeballing
our guys get it out really fast yourself
now camera wasn't on me with fingers do
we should just claim that we should just
you've had ter have you not I've been
doing it for years you got to be careful
you don't do that a BML rally oh my my
pops Crowder has a story about that in
Detroit at the mall Tourette's involved
Tourette's and and the word what is the
chances of racist Tourette's that's what
this guy the subset that's what this guy
had and he said it surrounded by black
people serious yes this actually
happened maybe we'll bring him in on M
he can tell the story seen that yeah my
my dad kind of saw him for a while I was
like what's going to happen here you
know at the purple suit store or
wherever they were and uh he looked
around like and my oh no and they they
seem to understand but I don't know he
probably got his ass kicked in the
parking lot okay
so speaking of someone who deserves one
LeBron James uh this week and here's the
I want to offer a solution to you with
this segment because the segment is a
little childish but we all are and he
found a whole new way LeBron James to uh
completely disrespect the country that
has made him a multi-millionaire and I
can't believe we haven't done this yet
and we were YouTube is very selective
when we did one on Don Lemon a long time
[Music]
ago
he was attending his son's uh game at
USC and it far beyond you know Colin
kernick um comparing himself to the you
know the slaves of of of roots for a $40
million signing bonus uh Lebron refused
to even acknowledge the flag or the
national anthem I can't believe he know
knows his
son baby steps that's a win true we give
him that much here's a
clip came in late
[Laughter]
[Music]
unusual also he didn't tip the uh the
escort what a piece of right this
is LeBron pretend now he'll say oh I
wasn't aware
there's there's no excuse for it hold on
hold on he's he plays that specific
sport he knows the rhythm of the game
when they're standing out there and
everybody just happens to have their
hands on their hearts and they start to
escort you to the seat you go wait a
second the national anthem is playing
let me Focus right instead of going in
walking to your seat and kind of looking
around sitting down not even
acknowledging what's going on it's just
disrespectful well that's him and he can
of course he can be disrespectful all he
wants he just the problem is he can't be
the victim when you have to deal with
backlash so that's LeBron pretending
that America sucks here's LeBron James
pretending to read you're holding the
autobiography of Malcolm X along with
Alex Haley I don't know how far you are
into the book but what's your biggest
takeaway so far um I kind of just
started a couple days ago um I'm on the
forward but um I've read Cofe a lot of
notes over the years this my first time
actually reading this from start to
finish him understanding the the play
how powerful um The Negro can be he used
that word a lot okay me too here's
LeBron pretending to be an intellectual
yeah yes of course no
lenses you should be handing you a mint
the menum nice hat and here is LeBron uh
pretending although I I will say he's
he's been pretending so long I don't
think it's like it's like Al it's like
Marilyn Manson he doesn't know where the
pretend LeBron ends and the real LeBron
begins he can't hear the laughter
anymore here's LeBron pretending to be a
master of rhetoric
LeBron come on
that's smart LeBron smart LeBron smart
where you guys to defend home court this
point uh well I mean are you a smart
guy
right what a piece of no he's just
a pompous Jacker here he is pretending
also to be I guess just what he was
asking the pretending to be smart that
guy coach gives us that freedom he gives
us all the freedom in the world to do
what we want to do on the offens end as
long as we do what he want us to do I
mean do what we want you know what I
mean
yeah on the defensive end
[Music]
yeah to be
oppressed there you go I think he can
though yeah he can he's been and uh
here's LeBron actually trying to swim
[Music]
we can't be all things to all people
wait a what the fck was
that I don't even get that somebody help
me out you will good it it'll come to
you no but why the river it'll sink in
Nick look you will understand that other
such other such things of that
nature I always find it funny when he
tries to get really articulate tries I
try to get articulate for my
articulateness what why did you bring a
book to an interview that you haven't
started why why' you not but it it seems
like something to just hold I don't know
why it sounds like like Tracy Morgan now
yo I'm reading Michael that guy said
negro all the time that's a powerful
word that's a powerful word yeah you're
a
pregnant why why do you do that I'm
going buy myself a masera see how fast
it could
go
so uh Lebron here's the thing and this
is why he's just s I'm I what just such
a piece of he claims to care about
the oppressed but here he is sing for
China the people who by the way you know
jail and beat Wagers to death yeah those
people after an NBA General oh he read
it in the Malcolm X book an NBA general
manager called to free Hong Kong and
LeBron was like no no hold on a second
uh what China does is is is great right
he wasn't educated on on on the
situation at hand and um and he spoke
and so many people uh could have been
harmed um not only financially but
physically emotionally the weers um so
just be careful what we what we tweet
and we say and what we do now what he
really means is that his pocketbook
could be harm yes what a piece of
and I know some of you are saying what's
a pocketbook look the world existed
before
you that's one that pisses me off the
most because it should be very easy for
him to get behind another oppressed to
people that are obviously being
oppressed and just say yeah they should
probably change how they do things in
China instead he's like he wasn't
educated on the situation no I think the
problem is he was LeBron why don't you
educate us and for you young people po
book is what your mother would cling to
if LeBron got on the
elevator or Subway or Subway that's you
know you know what's what really that
about that latest incident with him
sitting down he comes in during The N he
knows the whole world the eyes are on
him yeah in that in that Stadium he
knows that so he's like if I sit on
they'll all see what a dick I am no you
think he he thinks that all eyes are on
the short white guy who can still play
college basketball Bob koo's great
grandson wearing a bathing suit and
shoot from
his do an underhanded that work it can
work it can work that's how I bll now
here's the thing he's he's saying oh
yeah he should educate himself just keep
just for some context to put a finer
point on it and all references are
available at L Earth credit.com because
you'll think that this isn't real I
assure you it
is this is the culture that LeBron James
thinks is better than
[Music]
[Applause]
America's I have to uh to be to be fair
that was a that was a San Francisco
crime initiative that was they put them
in and they're sucked out to Oakland I
got that's the first time I've agreed
with LeBron that commercial is I've had
that in my head for a million years oh
no black person go Oakland we suck in
person from Berkeley in a perfect world
we could all have a commercial like that
yes exactly Mexicans could do it to you
know what I mean it will be yeah exactly
it'll be seriousy Chileans with
peruvians but we wouldn't be able to
tell so they'd have to label them well
absolutely like Peruvian Jersey
I don't know the difference lower third
or something yeah lower third I don't
either I just know they hate each other
I know I had Chile and friends they were
super friendly people so he mentioned
Peruvian like oh stevea you're a like
what about
peruvians what' you say I know and
that's how you piss liberals off you
lump that stuff in on purpose I was at a
comedy seller I said to the guy in front
what do you Puerto Rican he goes I'm
Colombian I go what's a difference a
half a
gram youe laugh they got a about guy
well don't do that with gay William he
does not like the Puerto Ricans because
he's Cuban is he is very very hey hit
the like button if you want to see
LeBron traded to the Shanghai
sharks that's a thing probably too isn't
it oh it takes his the uh the Trevor
Boward uh treatment with his lawyer
Brian Freeman gets someone to come
forward with fake black eyes and hey all
of a sudden you know he's playing ball
in China or Japan here's the thing
LeBron is it's not just that he is is uh
is wrong he's also very disingenuous you
see that with China uh you also see this
with him you know pretending to care for
example about the inner city youth so
his I promise school in Ohio is failing
its students the references are
available at l.com let me give you some
some numbers here uh in the school only
two per 2% of the students are
proficient in math and for those of you
who may have attended the school so
you're mathematically challenged that
means that 98% are not
proficient English 3% of LeBron School
are proficient again if you've attended
the school that means that 97% of all
students are not proficient in English
well they're doing
better and there's also already been a
shooting at the school and LeBron's
reaction was what you'd
expect now I know that that seems if
you're listening on audio you've been
spared something dark so
ouch here's the UFC fighter Kobe
Covington who by the way I don't know
like I get that he's also disingenuous
but the reason that he can say this is
because he's tapping into something
where people Society at large are tired
of the LeBron of the world here is Kobe
Covington uh calling out LeBron James's
uh disrespect for the United States of
America in a very silly outfit you hate
America so much and and you don't like
this country that gave you a billion
dollars leave it or come deal with me
you go to China go to go to these sweat
shops that you employ all these laborers
and use these women and pay them Pennies
on the dollar to make your Millions F
you L Dr James you're a coward you're a
spin coward you're
a I like him yeah you know it's always
uncoverable though when someone like
drops the mic and it's like no you're
not there yet yeah just just that's
right he cut off the last like oh is
that the end I guess that's a mic drop
yes that speech would have been much
more effective he if he wasn't dressed
like flave of flave the send a
mixed signals there and he stole that
bit a little bit from CH chill chill son
and actually had an actual disagreement
with LeBron but always talked a bunch of
trash if you guys go back and watch this
and now they're fine so maybe he'll be
mad that I say this because now they are
fine uh he just was at an a press
conference and said LeBron knows what he
did and next time that I see him you
know we we'll we'll have to we'll have
to solve the issue we'll resolve it
LeBron had his agent reach out to CH
call and apologize people are thinking
what you think CH Sun would beat beat
LeBron's ass within an inch of his life
you think play everyone thinks that
these basketball players are tough I'm
sure they're large I'm sure that they're
athletic do you have any idea what a
professional fighter does to LeBron
James he folds him backwards and foot
puts him in a lock that's
exactly anyway did you have something
you okay so apparently the United States
is so racist that uh a black kid born
into poverty with a 16-year-old single
mother can earn $430 million playing
basketball $900 million in endorsement
deals that's a lot of nuts business
ventures like Pepsi Walmart Nike also
obviously racist companies uh you know
over a billion dollars if you add up the
revenue now um possible that he spends
all of it in the next four
months half of it right up his nose am I
right you think you think you can make
that kind of money in China being dumb
as a bag of hammers oh God that's one of
those things it's like he's he's a very
he's a fundamentally unintelligent
person who has not he doesn't need to
think about these issues and this is the
problem is look he's got a big platform
yes right yes people assume because
you're successful you must be successful
in all things it's like assuming that I
don't know that that uh that Joe Rogan
because he does a podcast knows about
computers no no he uses a computer but
it doesn't mean that he does just
because he's a very successful comedian
just because LeBron James is very
successful at basketball doesn't mean
that he knows anything about the world
he's illiterate and wears fake
glasses wait a minute we talking about
the Harvard president you know what at
this point tomato racist heck it's all
the same tomato sweet potato yes yes and
here's the here's the thing you know
what look I'm not saying that this
person can't be an idiot I'm not saying
that this person doesn't deserve the
right to play of course look team wants
him but how about this how about uh if
every single one of you right now uh
every single person who could possibly
actually consider the issue at hand of
LeBron being racist and hating this
country while sing for China how about
you just treat him like The Ungrateful
piece of that he is never buy watch
support anything relating to him ever
again what what if if the NBA finals
were playing and he was in that in that
game and was playing on a Jumbotron in
your yard you wouldn't even lift the
shade it's like the the ghosts in Super
Mario World you turn your back on them
they start but you know just it's a
reverse ghost you turn your back on
they'll disappear I understand that the
ghosts in Super Mario World would chase
you if you turned your back so it was a
bad analogy on me you can admonish me
admon you can admonish me ad the point
is he thrives on your attention
[Music]
don't
I can't believe I'm not a billionaire I
was saying that crap about Abdul Jabar
in the late 70s yeah and now you know
that shows you how slow like you know
now the UFC guys are coming around right
yeah it
sorry before it was popular um I have my
finger on all this crap well that's the
thing Bill Russell I was badmouthing you
had the trail blaz and then everyone
else comes comes in and claims credit
that's right it's kind of like when all
of a like Alex Jones gets rep platformed
it's like well great I wonder if someone
else did that by the way uh 12 Days of
Christmas giveaways at crowers shop.com
the winner of the PlayStation 5 is Julie
thing that's a BS name from uh
Massachusetts it's got to be sud thing
congratulations so and starting today
every purchase at cred shop
if you want to buy some things for
Christmas and if you don't that's fine
gets you entered to win a Blackstone
grill yeah so a lot of people were
saying hey can we get ni those are
awesome I have one do you you really
yeah I've heard they're good I don't
have one I just make scrambled eggs with
it that's about it oh well that's a
griddle no it's a it's a the grill no
but a grill has
a like a girl you have a black stone top
yes yeah that's not a grill it is it's
not a grill you can't make okay try and
make scrambled eggs on a grill it's
going to fall through the crack yeah
he's the soundboard LeBron no I do I
scramble my eggs and I over easy my eggs
and things of that nature and
such act like you don't like my eggs oh
come on you stop pontificating about
your eggs now so let's go to YouTube If
this hasn't happened yet today they just
uh openly shadowbanned us uh here and I
get it look we're just we're just
covering this so you guys kind of
understand we've suspected this for
years we've talked about it but this is
the first time that we've received an
email where they just like yeah that's
what we're doing so that's good that
you're problem yeah they don't have any
honestly that shows the power sorry of
this show that Google has a problem with
you yeah well powerful company in the
world has an issue with what you're
doing well they don't want to ban this
just to be clear they do not want to ban
this show cuz exactly because it would
be tan out saying no conservatives are
welcome look I'm basic pumpkin
spice conservative like nothing is that
controversial they can't so they don't
want to ban this show they don't want to
ban you they don't want you to
understand that they want your money but
they don't want your views your opinions
they want your views as far as eyeballs
and ears to generate ad revenue for them
for companies like Viacom and Turner and
NBC Universal and ABC all of that but
they don't want your opinions to be
permitted on the platform because those
advertisers don't like your opinions you
see it out in the open with Twitter
Youtube tries to claim that it's not
happening so they don't want to ban us
they suspend us all the time develop
strikes and they never give us actual
answers or rules but the worst uh part
about that is or what I should say
what's more
uh invasive what happens is is something
that you don't see where they just
remove people's ability to make a living
so they can claim we're not censoring
right but they're actually it would be
like let's say you run a business let's
say you run a business right now if I
don't know you run a salon we nailed up
the front of your salon so that nobody
could enter and put a tarp over and said
but we didn't shut down your salon you
can still cut hair yeah but no one's
allowed in also this is a fire
hazard so YouTube sent an email today
this came from poo Alto to remove any
data says hi Crowder bits that's one of
our channels to help keep our community
safe oh Jee I know we limit some of our
more powerful features to channels who
have built and maintained a positive
Channel History who have provided or who
have provided verification pause here
really
quickly positive Channel History
shouldn't the metric for that be if
people interact with the channel and
want to watch the content yes because on
a pound-for-pound basis no channels
performed better than we did as far as
people getting the kind of content that
they wanted so YouTube says no
we consider it not to be a positive
Channel History so we're going to remove
your ability to reach people who have
subscribed to you so by the way if
you're on YouTube right now make sure
you hit the notification Bell um
obviously Rumble is our priority but hey
we want to be a thorn in their side so
just go and check it yourself they also
write as of now your channel doesn't
have sufficient Channel History that's a
lie what what it has lost access to
Advanced features this may have happened
because our uh your channel did not
follow our community this may have
happened because even though it's not
true we even reached out to the customer
service line but of course they're not
the quickest and everybody outsources
these
days meet Vijay who is one of our team
leaders who is grown from an ENT level
to a team leader position today managing
team of close to 30 people yes that was
a man with no arms using his feet that's
how you know you're a slave are your
feet Broken Oh I have no arms your feet
don't work you can dial a
phone it Shan him an a missed two weeks
of work as athletes
foot to a poster of John Madden
connecting What the fu but you can't
clean a keyboard for the guy come on
somebody help him out how do I get
Seaman out of a mouse pad I don't know
my friend have you tried club soda yes
club soda and salt
and because the club sort of makes the
athletes foot the to rise out of the
keybo and the salt then absorbs it
rendering it
inert I was thinking you were saying it
was the Indian gu like more importantly
how did he get it on the mouse P that's
true what you what do you have you never
used the porn
before arm arms arm I was talking about
myself not him oh well we were confused
don't understand the mechanics biology
so according to YouTube very flexible
and let's I'm sure that that had to have
the I'm sure that probably was D on
YouTube I don't know they have the dump
button out there so I just want to make
sure there's enough time here that we
come back because I want to read this on
YouTube okay good we should be here yeah
so according to the YouTube overlords we
lost our and this is the part that is
key right we are not banned from YouTube
now we've been demonetized for a very
long time but we've lost our privilege
to meaning anyone who expresses the
kinds of opinions so take our opinions
and anything even further than that just
imagine that for a second this is
considered unacceptable we've lost our
privilege to I quote get higher daily
limits for live stream shorts video
uploads to embed live streams to pin
comments to add external links to your
video descriptions they have limited and
by the way they've limited our daily
reach so again it's oh you're not banned
you're allowed to be here we're just
going to make sure that nobody sees it
we're going to make sure that you get no
Revenue which we're fine mug Club that's
why you guys exist and now we're going
to make sure that hold on a second let
me give you the sequence actually just
to make this very very clear okay we
have Vox head apocalypse you guys
haven't violated our
guidelines but people are calling for
your head so going to demonetize you all
right then we find a way to remain
monetized outside of YouTube you were
funded by viewers like you that's why
mug Club is so important and we're able
to take people over to rumble ler.com
mugclub you get the copy of beautiful
differences you get Nick depalo you get
Alex Jones you get Taj you get all of
these that's why we built what we've
built we said fine you want to
demonetize us okay we'll be funded by
viewers like you then they say well we
don't want you to be able to do that
either so we're just going to shut off
your reach to anyone so that you can't
gain any new
viewers nothing about this nothing about
this constitutes being a platform which
is the umbrella of the law under which
they are protected nothing about it
nothing and every single time those
emails come in because you send them to
me and we look at them and they say you
may have violated our community
guidelines they sometimes say in this
vague kind of way but they never give
you time codes like that would be the
obvious thing if you're trying to
correct behavior let's just assume that
YouTube is trying to correct our very
bad behavior yes they would say you said
this at time code this you can't say
that they will never hang their hat on
anything because it pins them down we
we've literally had conver we said hold
on just tell us exactly what it is they
say I can't tell you that and we say why
say because you're a conservative so I
mean that's paraphrasing but YouTube
won't provide us with specifics and
since they haven't provided us with
specific SP strikes we can only assume
at this point that Beyond demone ation
now you won't be able to enjoy these
privileges of basic channels by the way
other channels that aren't monetized in
other words if you were to Simply create
a YouTube channel right now you would
have more privileges than what we've
built yeah than us this is obviously
Viewpoint discrimination which is not
just us it's it's you it's you it's all
of you we cannot stress that enough
that's why we have everyone go over to
rumble but we understand baby steps I
get it a lot of you still use YouTube
It's ubiquitous this is why we rep
platformed Alex Jones this is why we
want to make sure that you guys know
about Nick depalo the OG who by the way
has been banned from so many places I've
lost count for these kinds of views and
the difference is the important thing to
keep in mind is these are your views
they just want to they want you to feel
alone they want you to feel as though
there are far more Americans out there
uh who believe that our government is
transparent and we host the freest and
fairest elections of all time there are
far more and you're an outlier there are
far more Americans out there who believe
that there's been nothing uh no one has
run a foul of the of the FDA laws or or
skirted them or reduced liability or we
haven't seen any complications
associated with the MRNA injections and
heart complications particularly with
young men they want you to feel like
you're an outlier that no abs everyone
else out there is on board with kneeling
for the anthem like LeBron there aren't
you're just if you think differently
you're racist Colin kernick everyone
agrees with him you're racist just look
at the NFL look they support it look at
YouTube look at Instagram look at Tik
Tok you oh wait hold you think that we
shouldn't be sending hundreds of
billions of dollarss committing it to
Ukraine well you're just an extreme and
then they come out and they call you an
extremist and they give us no reasons as
to how they are labeling us effectively
extremist here this actually here best
illustrates lad with crder trying to
dodge set
strikes excuse me we'd like it to have
this
flower excuse me sir would you donations
for the Reverend
Moon Sho for Jesus all read about
Jehovah's
Witness how about Buddhism
I'm Jerry's Kids oh yes Scientology more
nuclear
power let me give you an
example of uh just some some things that
we have seen and this how how much if
you add this up across all other right
leaning channels um you know if you add
this up across and I don't know how many
there are but certainly people who are
willing to take risks take this times it
by 50 by 100 so when we were monetized
uh on YouTube we were gaining an average
this is from I mean just from 2018 to
2019 158,000 new subscribers a month
that means that in an equal Market of
ideas we were gaining 158,000 new people
not who were watching that number was in
the tens of millions people who said I
want to subscribe to this Channel and
hear more demonetized after the Vox
apocalypse that plummeted down to 43,000
new subscribers a month in other words
it's like they've shut down the street
on which our shop exists we were
Accidentally remonetized In September of
2020 it was a huge accident they fixed
it quick for like 4 months and it went
right back up to close to 100,000 new
subscribers a month again now we're in a
free Marketplace of ideas permanently
demonetized went down to 15,000 a month
it's not about the money it's you m Club
fine we we've made up for it and we're
not beholding advertisers the issue is
we're not conservatives are being
forbidden anyone who's right from
reaching new people because they know
that if people on the right reach new
people we win you win you are an army
that's what changed my mind is go out
change some Minds have the conversation
with everyone you can and use every
platform that you have available to you
because they can't remove us all they
don't want to remove us all because they
need your money that's the disconnect
the disconnect is they need the money of
the people of the the PBS they need your
money but they want to make sure that
your points of view are not permitted
and so they go after people who at the
top of that food chain and some people
play ball some people play ball and
that's really disappointing for uh an ex
another example reference is available
at lc.com we put the link in the
description 2019 project varas verified
that our show was completely throttled
manually by Facebook they actually
entered in code on Facebook so that our
page wouldn't Reach people so and that's
uh overlay F I believe that you have
there and uh this is from The Insider
said I would see this appear on several
uh different conservative Pages uh and I
saw it on Steven Crowder's page as well
as a daily caller's page that there were
and we saw this you can see there was a
video all of the code that they faked in
on Facebook so it's happened on Facebook
it's happened on YouTube it's happened
on Google we've been banned from Tik Tok
which is kind of funny and then uh of
course it happens on Instagram what
happened before that people like Nick
depalo OG talks about it now you have
some comedians out there who people say
oh they're ruthless he was getting
banned from comedy clubs and I think
it's fine now it's not a source spot
because he was saying the things that
now other people are saying and trying
to sell you that they took the risk no
he took the risk no Alex Jones took the
risk people who we have that's why mug
Club exists mug Club undercover they're
willing to to take the risk because this
is what they shut down your ability to
make a living to be clear wars were
fought for Less this is the context
people say and you can see this from
black and white on the gray issues
yesterday they all agreed when they were
talking about Dave Chappelle they said
well you know you can say what you want
but people if they don't want to support
you I said great but it's not about
people not wanting to hear what you have
to say shutting you off it's about other
people in power saying I'm going to
ensure that even the people who have
already bought a ticket can't see you
that's the issue that is not
accountability cult
that is societal
manipulation and they're they're ramping
it up before the election you think it
was happen St that we were banned from
YouTube the last primaries think of that
yeah think of if 17 million more people
like in the last general election were
watching the primaries you know what
five 10 million people hey consider the
fact that swing state differences are
down to 10,000 votes you think 17
million people makes a difference I
think it makes a huge difference and and
look it's it's that half the country
shares this Viewpoint like we're not not
saying anything that's breaking the law
right like if we were breaking the law
and saying something that was just
horrendous and causing somebody to go to
somebody else's house and saying hey go
do this to this person but we're not
doing that no and you can shove The
Young Turks in front of people's faces
and they have this terrible horrific
View and they're really bad and that's
totally fine and that's monetizable you
can totally do that that that that's the
penis or dildo I can't see the first
word I think that was monetized if I
remember correctly dick or dildo was a
game yeah wasn't age restricted at the
it was a game where it was a gay man
would lay down with a C and the man
behind him would insert something into
and he would play and he would have to
guess if it's a dick or dildo by the way
spoiler alert it's always dick always
every single time but we pass up that
opportunity we wouldn't have needed Elon
Musk if these guys would just go out
there and be neutral and tell
advertisers to go screw themselves
because listen if those advertisers go
away fine there's plenty that want to
reach the other half of Americans that
don't share that Viewpoint yeah let
other advertisers come into the
marketplace we wouldn't have needed Elon
Musk to come in and buy Twitter convert
it into X and then tell Bob Iger to go f
himself right right you wouldn't have
needed that you need these platforms to
be open Hest because that's what they
sold as well they said come and have
your channel here have your audience
here share your Viewpoint and then they
changed the game for so many people and
thank God places like Rumble exist
because if it didn't exist right now
where would we be right we' be getting
banned on YouTube we'd have to walk on
some egg shows we'd still be freaking I
don't know you guys can at some point to
I'm even considering like you know what
I'm just going to get off all social
media and if you guys go to rumble you
want to send up for the mailing list I
just I just don't want to do it anymore
it's a constant everchanging rule book I
don't know so you know sometimes you can
transcend it we may be at that point I
get that you have to reach people where
they you guys can comment below I'm just
I'm just tired of the whole thing yes
yeah I just I just don't I don't care
enough I don't care enough about that
anymore if they're going to throttle it
then okay well then fine you guys are
enough and you know what you guys can be
the people who go out and let people
know either we create something that you
want to watch or you don't and uh they
want to ensure that you don't see it so
it's incumbent upon us to make something
worthwhile and you guys let us know and
then you can let other people know I'm
tired of the from them
especially going into the election I
don't mean that to be hope I mean it to
say I think that that might be the
solution just people with big enough
names going we're off we're gone done
buy Instagram buy YouTube at some point
that's where this is headed because
that's what they want anyway and then
when they feel the sting of the lack of
money from at least half of the United
States of America well it'll be too late
hey speaking of saying horrible things
were you about to say something NE you H
I was going to say wait that's what no
he held up his finger and I couldn't see
I just want SK
it you don't have that kind of
Tourette's Nick he does now he can turn
it on and off question I'm sorry
ni how much money do they lose by that's
the problem they're so loaded right now
but like you said if half of America
does it they'll feel it right but right
now they don't no correct right well
right now they the problem is they're
still in that uh YouTube is starting to
make money but they were losing money
for a very long time I mean Twitter
loses money year-over year that's still
the case but Google the parent company
yeah exactly and they have a giant
Monopoly so they have the time you know
write a lot of these it's called tyny I
believe that's really what it is and it
is because by the way it's enabled by
the government these are not private
companies these companies are more
powerful than National governments have
ever been in the past and they have the
stamp of approval and they work hand
inand with the intelligence agencies how
do we know because they said So speaking
of actually horrible
things then I would say join M Club
because we'll say horrible things on M
Club letter with credit for sure things
that are unspeakable absolutely and you
know although this children's book is
nice it's just you know it's
nonpolitical and if you really want to
see things that are completely
unspeakable watch Nick at 5:00 p.m. yes
oh boy but even worse than that how am I
still on I don't even understand
President we got your back but PR and
this one has a very thick back we're
about to discuss president Claud
president gay you know of Harvard yay
president gay uh in comparison if
president gay had a YouTube channel it
would be thrust into your timeline I
have no doubt oh God you said this about
all the calls for the genociding of the
Jews on campus all that and Dr Gay at
Harvard does calling for the genocide of
Jews violate Harvard's rules of bullying
and harassment yes or no it can be
depending on the context what's the
context targeted as an individual
targeted as at an individual hates Jews
hates Jews I got that sound
Dr use it all the 10 you inspired me for
that thank you
Nick now you've seen that that was just
okay a refresher here because apparently
now gay will face no consequences
because you saw what happened at pen
yeah sorry upen upen yeah not pen not
Penn State I want to be very very clear
uh you saw what happened that's the you
know but they have they have a rough
history too so at upen I respect sand
dusy more than
this two sides of the same coin that's
right so gay is apparently now not going
to face any consequences and she will be
remaining president uh despite hating
the Jews clad gay will remain the
president of Harvard University despite
public outcry over her comments during a
congressional hearing about
anti-Semitism on college campuses this
comes after more than 700 faculty
members signed a letter in defense of
her so let me ask you even know that
last part 700 morons signed a letter in
defense so let me get this straight
calling for wiping out all Jews fine
calling for wiping out one Jew is a
problem I don't understand do they
understand math it depends on the Jew
jald depends in the Jew are we talking
har Weinstein is a bad Jew that's bad
Jew but so stupid we're talking Oscar
Shin a great Jew love the Shindler saved
a lot of other Jews do they know what
genocide means maybe there's a a
deficiency in their vocabulary I don't
know I know what you I know you are but
what am I Jew hater that's what you are
not myself I love Jews too much that's
my problem people say you love Jews too
much I say
no just enough just they say I say just
the right amount they say you love Jews
too much what do you do oh
[Music]
God
next comment I cannot imagine you
shouldn't be hitting the dump there's no
one out there to hit the YouTube dump
today hey someone's getting fired
oh we're not on R yet it's right fired
no no we're always on I mean we're on
Rumble fired we're up we were on YouTube
and I don't know how long uh Elizabeth
McGill at upen made similar comments had
to resign what could possibly be
different Jalia no that's the Guess Who
one and that's the wrong guess who
character side by side of Mill from upen
there you go ah oh I get it Mill and
point guard from the Pistons by the way
I'm horribly dis is that Isaiah Thomas
wow that's right Jewish name Isaiah
Thomas love
him at the very least his captain no
longer wears his hat that's what they
say never showered with them but I've
heard good
things
so it's so dead gay was also accused of
plagiarizing her thesis well that's a
problem which brings us to I guess white
black edition of uh rules for thee and
not for
[Music]
me all right so we're going to do this
in reverse a little bit let's set up
from the perspective of you know method
act here president gay considers okay
rules for me rules for president gay and
how these don't apply to you this is the
issue of Elites in power and people who
are uh supposedly marginalized and
oppressed groups which include the likes
of President gay and LeBron James so
when it comes to the plagiarism of
course she gets a pass right so the
Harvard Corporation said the university
has the university became aware in late
October of allegations regarding three
articles three on December 9th the
fellow the fellows reviewed the results
which revealed a few instances of
inadequate citation plagiarism president
gay is proactively requesting for
Corrections in two articles to insert
citations and quotation marks that were
omitted from the original Publications
no no no no no no no she's not
proactively doing anything you
discovered a problem and reacting and
she's like hey hey can you change that
yeah president gay where you wrote here
there is nothing to fear but fear itself
yeah and then you actually wrote squeak
squeak squeak goes my wheelchair were
you stealing
this yes but I would like you to change
never heard of him in my life who
unbelievable we didn't have a president
sitting in a wheelchair you're crazy
ridiculous you mean that old white guy
with the goofy legs so little mo and
here's here's the 1619 project author if
you remember uh Nicole Hannah Jones
defended president gay and we'll get to
the rules for you you're a student yeah
kid well take a guess why ready to hit
that dump button defend president gay
saying this so when you think about the
fact that Harvard this nation's oldest
university had had about a
370e explicit racial quota of only
hiring white men uh to be the president
um it's laughable to think that the
first ever black woman um following that
unbroken line of white racial quotas is
the one who's unqualified I mean this is
kind of the beauty of how racism works
well she did fill the uh the uh pocket
knife Swiss army ring toss quota true
you will never miss a game of horseshoes
if you're around dolphin to jump
through
that why you jumping through my
earrings I you know what I I'm
encouraged though I am encouraged by
what we heard there because she says
racial quotas are
racist that's good white racial quotas
no come on had it for a second come on
now you think she wants Asians in there
yeah
exactly dang it notice you don't want
equal representation on the basketball
team only when it applies to stem fields
and Jess that's what I'm saying yeah
white people found at Harvard and
do they have any idea how some
society's evolve at yes
understand I know and then you benefit
from the fact that these people said ah
you know what okay there was a peri of
entry and you know we created this
school and hey cool now let's but now
you've gone too far but I just love how
she sidesteps it no no we're not talking
about that we're talking about direct
plagiarism four times I don't know
nothing about that so let's contrast
that the person who gay plagiarized so
we're interest in the comment there from
the 1619 project author um this is the
person who was a direct vict an actual
victim of plagiarism this person is a
legal scholar Dr Carol Swain who called
out president gay it won't ever not be
funny in Harvard I believe they're doing
this because they don't want to fire
their first ever black president someone
who was clearly a
Dei appointee by the way right on the
money she's right on the money great
great statement unfortunately after that
she was fooled by Kevin
[Music]
mallister and the streak continues I
have no idea what movie two things can
be true and let you know what let
comment below this is something that's
gone on for a long time I you know this
in comedy right absolutely but a lot of
prominent figures by the way who've been
ACC and when I say accused I mean
there's a lot of verified evidence of
plagiarism like uh Martin Luther King Jr
people like xingping if you'd like us to
do a segment on just famous plagiarists
I just didn't want to do that today
because a lot of people would get upset
without the whole context yeah and and
just just so you're like oh she made no
no no no no no no your thesis are you
kidding me do you know how long people
work on that months and said president
gay no months and months and months and
you have somebody reviewing it before it
goes before a committee and then that
committee comes back and says no it's
not good enough this was not a mistake
this was somebody deliberately trying to
make themselves look smarter than they
actually are it's called lowering the
standards out of fairness we've been
doing it for Less 80 years and look
where we are yeah can we turn it the
around Whitey are you going to wake
up yeah well look you even have the
black lady who was plagiarized she was
pissed yeah yeah don't expect that to be
on the news like a morphine drip like
they will anytime they happen to find de
hire like oh oh yeah I know she nailed
it and that's the rules for me for
president gab but rules for thee if
you're a student ah okay uh at Harvard
get I know what you're thinking so I'm
allowed to copy other people's work no
of course not cuz you're not a black
president who happens to be gay and look
like a kiss who character gay that's
right so this is the handbook she checks
more boxes than an illegal
OBGYN
God so many l
that is a beautiful one that is
fantastic you make Bill Burr look like a
lamb is he the bad boy is that the
standard the standard and I love his
comedy pleas no come on come on now he's
like I can do worse than a Tuesday of
course my gosh uh I really hate he fakes
it anyways the
handbook Nick depalo would say things to
make billberg go dude dude what he can't
say that right he just waiting for a
hail of Black Fist to Cal
down got to warn me first Nick he just
thinks he could say whatever cuz he's
like a guinea well I was I was thinking
it so I said it got to look around first
oh my god dude you both came up through
Boston obviously and my point is you are
the guy some people think Bill is funny
guy ruthless defines Nick I left the M
we had a little text fight probably a
year ago and and uh talking about right
whatever and I made the crazy statement
of saying well um a lot of our social
problem this country stem from the
dissolution of the African-American
family I'm not the first one to say that
right and then he left a like a
voicemail D you're astoundingly ignorant
on that
one you know I me what I'm surprised you
didn't have an aneurism when oh D I had
to go and he's been on your show I know
you guys have done I had him on once but
he I think I told on your show a few
times I went out there to do his I to do
uh Joe Rogan show a couple times Billy
said yeah I'll have you on my show while
you're out there I asked them if I could
yeah said yes both times when I get out
there last minute I'm sure his wife put
the kabash on that yeah well she give
and I know Nia actually from she used to
work at tough Crow you know uh but I'm
hoping it was his wife I hope it wasn't
him yeah that said no he you know last
minute twice no look I and it bugs me
because I do I I absolutely love his
comedy and and I don't know I that guy
might might like him more than he likes
I think he pretends to like me no I
think what it is is I don't know I don't
know if I should I don't okay you tell
what I think I watch you on op and
Anthony look we're we're going it's this
little inside baseball you can go back
and listen to op and Anthony uh which
was a show uh if you don't know is on
SiriusXM and Nick was on there there was
a show called tough crowd with Colin
Quinn and Nick was on there he was a
regular with Geraldo Patrice O'Neal
Norton um I know there were some but
that was kind of the stable of regulars
that's right and uh you can see an
episode where Bill bur very very funny
guy was there and was I would say in
that episode lost in Tall Weeds now
people develop but before that it's
almost like a moment that you can look
back and see it was more observational
wasn't nearly as kind of hard-hitting as
it became and I think a big part of a
lot of comics in Boston they Nick depalo
babies and they take it and they soften
it a little bit so they can appear to be
ruthless to a more mainstream audience
as opposed to Nick who literally just
says anything that comes to his head
like he has fake Tourette's but he's
been doing it for years it's comedy
Tourette got imag watching it
going I've been saying this for years
right I don't know why I'm that's more
Bill Burr than you but we sounded like
you know I'm like Nick just not as
racist and
at least vocally yeah I know he's
been married for like 35 years I'm sure
he goes home smashes her head in the
cabinet right he book The Wrong venue
like
that dude the black people watch this
show all right
it's stuck in my Crow when he said that
but so uh rules for the a little inside
baseball you guys can comment a few
again they all came up through Boston a
lot of guys came up through b Nick Joe
Rogan Bill Burr patri O'Neil Lou CK Dan
Cook after that before Dennis L you know
a lot of Sten Wright Jay Leno Conan
O'Brien yeah a lot of people came up
through Boston so it's not uh not crazy
it's like being a football player from
Texas well and it's not crazy I think
that people lift other not just material
but lift points of view and attitude I'm
not even accusing him of that I'm just
saying he's and and Billy like is I say
he's more liberal than he leads on but
and when I say liberal in a good way
even when we used to argue with the
comedy Celler table he kind of old
school liberal would try to look at both
sides right you know what I mean yeah
but you spend enough time in Hollywood
and uh it do your wife's an actress and
you know what I think it is I think it's
it's not just spending time in Hollywood
it's if you want to be a part of
Hollywood Ian you have people who go and
reject it and then you have people who
want to be a part of that club I think
that's what determines it because you
see A-list actors walking away and you
see people saying no I I want to be in
this club and that's what allows you to
kind of be molded and changed all right
same thing with Harvard which brings us
back go ahead I was goingon to say Colin
Quinn said her best about me I'm the
only guy who knows that burns Bridges
while he's standing on
them and as he gets older he's standing
on his
balls that's the word I
use bold all right so the rules for you
can you play your eyes like the
president in Harvard no here's the
handbook for Harvard students on
plagiarism and even improper attribution
says students who for whatever reason
like perhaps being a diversity president
oops submit work either not their own or
without clear attribution to its sources
will be subject to disciplinary action
up to an including requirement to
withdraw from the college right their
honor code also prohibits cheating
stating honor code members of the
Harvard College Community commit
themselves to producing academic work of
Integrity that is work that adheres to
the scholarly and intellectual standards
of accurate attribution of sources
appropriate collection and use of data
and transparent acknowledgment of the
contribution of others to their ideas
discoveries interpretations and
conclusions uh here's the thing just to
give you some context we right here at
this show making all the references
every day available at lc.com like a
bibliography and the link is in the
description do more due diligence than
the president of
Harvard true like it okay right here it
covers all of it you can't even do it
accidentally she did it very clearly
deliberately if you're a student you're
out
0.0 now I know somebody you were
thinking maybe we should give her the
benefit of the doubt because accidents
do happen and I understand that as we
just saw in this office earlier
today
God CNN's wilding out today you know
what I'm saying like everything anyway
I'm going to go to the fridge you need
anything no I'm good
thanks sh dude you
okay
what what are you saying
dude sh dude I think you hit your head
really hard man are you
[Music]
okay accidents happen yeah does he speak
Korean forever yeah for the
ladies it's a niche group no that not a
very do not underestimate the power the
motivating power of attractive Asian
ladies so this also goes back to rules
for me back to president
gay how do you say happy ending after
the October 7th you know Hamas uh
attacks where they brutalized people no
what happened uh president gay at that
on that dat supported free speech for
the first time in a while confirming uh
33 student groups right to support uh
Hamas okay now I know and just to be
clear people have the right to support
what they Free Speech as long as they're
not committing a crime calling for
genocide that actually is a little bit
of a gray area but that's rules for me
the rules for the president gay promoted
harford's Harvard's safis policy which
is aens to protect students from bad
ideas so defending from The River To The
Sea Jews live there by the way uh while
promoting safe spaces in Harvard from
bad ideas what would qualify president
gay no safe spaces for Jews yeah
including where they live I guess which
is ironic they actually have safe rooms
yeah I it's just unbelievable you can't
make the up and by the way
president gay also cancel lectures from
people who said yeah there are only two
genders ah so that's a harmful view this
is this is when people say oh the
Libertarians no no no just apply it
across the board you're being devoured
you are being devoured is there a
terrorist attack outside in the office
no I think they're
letting to
come to Joe Le Joe how are you a good I
heard there was SNES in this
mother I know we're talking about people
who don't like you the the Arabic look
at that tail he's very happy to be on
the show yeah guys he came in and he
left all right guys you can what are you
doing he's ready to go now guys he's
ready to get out yeah bye buddy he goes
look I don't need the Limelight yeah
need a ham sandwich in here to happy
he's more of a sug Knight than he is a
front guy he is yeah so she canceled
lectures from people who saying that
said that there were two genders and uh
at the same time say she defends Free
Speech these people are devouring you
you have to apply their standards to
themselves God bless you she also uh or
I should say Harvard uh rather rescinded
admission uh to 12 students I believe
it's 10 sorry it was initially reported
as 12 and 10 based on private group
chats private group chats think about
that we're sharing memes yeah now recall
in 20 Harvard ranked dead last in
freedom of speech free speech on Camp I
got to make a and she's only
getting her way we're just about to go
to mugler but go ahead now that's fine
go go go go go
go leave the headphones lay it down they
never kept good time anyway they're not
[Laughter]
stealing I don't think he understands
the concept of proximity effect with
microphones n no it's not yeah she's
only getting away with this because of
this intersectional hierarchy on this
oppression totem pole like we've talked
about right depends hold on today Jews
you're useful wait wait hold on a second
today stop Asian hate you're useful as
you're being pushed into the third rail
who's pushing them under the third rail
we don't want to talk about that okay
sorry today Jews you are no longer
useful because we have President gay who
looks like a Guess Who character and she
matches up with what we need to be
promoting today now you know what
doesn't exist on this hierarchy at all
your basic constitutional rights this is
something that people will say they'll
say oh the First Amendment talking about
YouTube and talking about what's going
on on campus they say the First
Amendment just prevents prevents the
government from silencing you hold on a
second the same thing with the Second
Amendment can be
argued do you forgo your basic human
rights inalienable means basic not civil
rights basic inalienable rights mean
endowed to you by God God gave you those
rights government Serv only do you forgo
those rights because he happened to be
on a campus who by the way receives
massive amounts of government funding
would not exist if not for government
funding the same thing applies to
YouTube who would not exist YouTube
Google Facebook if not for the massive
amounts of tax breaks they receed
from favorable government policies do
you foro that why do you foro your
Second Amendment right when you are
going to a university this is the thing
yes there are property rights and by the
way the left ironically I bet you if you
look into president gay they don't
believe in property rights they don't
believe in property because that's right
leftist idea cultural Marxism they
believe that property rights are
actually a tool of the Bourgeois to
inflict oppression onto the masses so
they don't believe in property rights
okay hold on a second I do but I still
don't believe that property rights where
this is a school where you have accepted
someone through the admission process
allows you to forbid them from not civil
rights basic human rights to
speech and to protect themselves I've
never understood that and you can also
make the argument and by make the
argument observe the fact that these are
wings of
government student loans why do you
think why why do you think admissions
are so you think it's because Harvard
has decided that's the marketplace of
degrees no it's because of all the
grants that exist out there grants
scholarships if you don't overcharge and
make something unaffordable so that
Uncle Sam fills in the Gap then you fail
to compete anytime government steps in
that's when you end up with a monopoly
duopoly triopoly or the land of higher
education you can apply the same thing
hey let's let's look at the companies
that receive or industries that receive
the most amount of government support
and intervention insurance companies
health insurance you a big fan ooh ooh
they were just they were rubbing their
grubby Paws in anticipation of Obamacare
Airlines big
fan education big fan energy companies
big fan think about it for a second and
in a lot of these sectors you forego
your basic human rights understand the
difference between a civil right and a
human right a human right is predicated
in people will use the term natural
rights and then the left will accuse you
of being racist if you use that term no
what we mean is government serves to
recognize and protect your rights it
doesn't Grant you the right to speak you
were born with the right to speak period
you were born with the right to defend
yourself period no one grants it to you
for some reason the institutions of
Higher Learning that are really supposed
to be a place to to Really to undergird
the understanding of basic human rights
for some reason in those places you
forfeit why and people on the right want
to act as though oh no so we have to be
consistent so we should allow them to do
no no no no no no no no no not at this
point where they have their finger on
the scales of Justice through government
subsidization and favoritism while they
silence you right now they are silencing
their students they're silencing their
students in Harvard Harvard you know
exactly what you're doing to students
who are there already you're silencing
them you're punishing them and you're
not allowing new ones to come in while
running interference for president
gay what about
that is
Justice I don't know you guys can
comment below and if you want to join
we're going to continue actually right
now talking about the Boston mayor yeah
who also hates white people and she's
Asian I don't know why you have to bring
that up Gerald I I mean I thought we had
I don't see
race oh I do lwith credit.com Club if
you're watching on Rumble you click that
button you get to keep watching it's
seamless uh and this show was just boy
we just said hey Nick's coming in let's
just make him let's the let's go LeBron
president gay and racist Boston mayor
Tourette's and Tourette's oh my God you
touched my heart letter to you Nick it
really is it really is so you can click
that button below I have no idea if
we're still on
YouTube uh thank you
Rumble do you want to do the honors and
tell YouTube to piss off yeah hey
YouTube go your
[Applause]
sister
yeah